it's the festive season in the country
but it's all under the shadow of a
pandemic
after months of lockdown and
restrictions the enthusiasm
is evident but caution is its first
casualty
even though the numbers of people at
gatherings have been restricted
these events are fair to be super
spreaders
in the markets footfalls are almost back
to pre-kobit 19 levels
with little signs of precaution traders
and businesses
gear up the whole year for diwali an
equivalent of christmas
and there is a sign of relief
we traders have gone through very
difficult times before this our business
was very shaky
we had problems getting food on the
table it was a hand-to-mouth existence
but now it's back and we are happy and
feel better
[Music]
with almost 8.7 million cases
india is the second worst affected
country after the united states
but with its poor record of public
health care the country still has one of
the lowest fatality rates
i think it was the lockdown our
government was decisive they were quick
and they did it at the right time which
was in march early march
and that really prevented millions of
people from getting covered
and prevented lots of people from dying
i mean that's one of the first and
foremost things
i think the credit entirely goes to the
prime minister for that
with a graded unlocking the poor have
made their choice
they take their chances between hunger
and a ravaging infection
that could be fatal
we are helpless as there is no work in
the villages
and the government is not listening
what to do it's an emergency there is no
money at home
i have to earn something for a living
that's why i've come here to earn money
[Music]
at this construction site most are
migrants
a negative rapid antigen test means
bread on the table for their families
as winter sets in and the air quality
gets worse
doctors fear the combination could see a
spike
even though the pandemic looms large
over this holiday season
the temple town of ayodhya was lit up by
more than
half a million oil lamps to celebrate
the festival of lights
bringing some respite and cheer in
people's lives
neville lazarus sky news delhi